die menschheit steht vor dem beginn
einer neuen ära der raumfahrt es wird
immer billiger den weltraum zu erreichen
es ist überhaupt nicht mehr utopisch
dass wir schon bald als touristen in den
weltraum reisen jetzt in clixoom science
und fiction nahezu unbemerkt von der
öffentlichkeit haben die amerikaner
wieder die flüge zur internationalen
raumstation iss aufgenommen
in diesen tagen wird die dritte mission
zur iss von amerikanischem boden staaten
csc es ist die zweite mission die fracht
zur iss mitnimmt mit an bord werden
spektakuläre experimente und technik
sein
was aber wirklich dabei bahnbrechend ist
dieser flug wird deutlich billiger sein
als alle bisherigen flüge zur iss nur
etwas über 50 millionen dollar wird der
flug in 400 kilometern höhe kosten
bisher sind es mit der service kapsel um
die 100 millionen dollar gewesen
ermöglicht hat dass dieser mann der
gründer von paypal und tesla dem
erfolgreichsten hersteller von
elektroautos weltweit allen masc er
hatte mit paypal und seiner zweiten
internetfirma siebter so viel geld
verdient dass er damit ein privates
raumfahrtunternehmen gründen konnte stay
sex mit der feldbahn rakete konstruierte
das unternehmen die erste privat
finanzierte rakete in den orbit
erreichen kann
der jetzt terminierte dritte flug mit
der deutlich größer und fällten ein
transportiert dabei das raumschiff
drängen zur raumstation
es ist das größte raumschiff das zurzeit
astronauten in den weltraum zu hass 2 ss
transportieren kann sieben personen
phase graf schiff transportiert es nur
fracht aber schon bald sollen menschen
mit der dragon 2 ss gebracht werden aber
auch für otto normalverbraucher soll
schon bald der flug ins all möglich sein
statt zahlreicher millionen sollen dann
schon schlappe 250.000 dollar für den
flug ins weltall reichen
auf der webseite von virgin galactic
können bereits flüge gebucht werden
das raumfahrtunternehmen hat anfang des
jahres ein
volk reichen testflug durchgeführt einem
regulären flugbetrieb steht also nichts
mehr im wege
bei deutschen galactic wird nicht
senkrecht abgehoben sondern der
raumgleiter startet von einem
trägerflugzeug und fliegt dann an die
grenze des weltalls rund 100 kilometer
über der erdoberfläche
das alles sind allerdings nur vorboten
einer kompletten veränderung der
raumfahrt raumgleiter wie das
spaceshuttle werden zurzeit entwickelt
hier der winzer der kann sogar in 400
kilometer höhe fliegen kommerzielle
flüge zum mond werden geplant und auch
private raumstationen sind mit
testmodellen unterwegs die sind
aufblasbare und den so aus es wird also
schon in absehbarer zeit eine menge
passieren was man ihr wollt ihr
irgendwann mal ins all fliegen oder
werden hier millionen dollars umsonst
für die raumfahrt verpulvert diskutiert
es in den kommentaren
mehr nachrichten aus dem weltall bei
klicks um gibt es hier
die gang theorie urknall aufgedeckt
links sind übrigens auch in der video
beschreibung das letzte video cebulla
epidemie ausgebrochen noch viel mehr
science und fiction news gibt's im blog
der ist da oben verlinkt und ich freue
mich natürlich über likes kommentare und
abos ein hinweis für die ältere
generation die sind kostenlos auf
youtube also bis dann bleibt dran